juillet 1990 les mohawks de kanesatake
etienne depuis cinq mois une barricade
sur un petit chemin de terre à proximité
du golf d'oka il se pose un projet de
condos auquel tient la municipalité mais
n'a jamais été question de céder un
pouce de terrain qui appartient
présentement la ministre les deux cas le
matin du 11 juillet la sûreté du québec
se présentant au corps l'objectif dé
faire la barricade
mais de l'autre côté des lactée de
montagne et saint louis les mois de
kahnawake leur réserve une surprise
ils bloquent le pont mercier la
stratégie des mois que sur le pont
appuyer leurs frères de cannes s
attaquer mais aussi déstabiliser la ssq
l'état-major de la sûreté du québec la
pression devient très forte
l'assaut est lancé
[Applaudissements]
là est ce qu on doit battre en retraite
humilié un policier le caporal demi est
mort mais c'est un miracle qu'il n'y ait
pas eu plus de victimes
et c'était bien camouflé bien caché il
voyait les policiers arriver j'aurais pu
toutes les tuiles
donc c'est un dérapage énorme ce matin
là l'anthropologue pierre trudel était à
l'époque l'un des rares s'intéresser au
moral de la région de montréal
j'ai commencé à donner des entrevues aux
médias à la justice et qu'il y ait un
autre ballon partait de loin pour
l'information
les morales de kahnawake cours la seule
voie qui relie château dit à montréal
[Applaudissements]
jour après jour la population
châteauguay se rassemblent au limite qui
sépare la ville qui est la réserve
l'ambiance est parfois festive mais il
ya surtout beaucoup de frustration et un
grand mépris à l'égard des monts rock
l'effigié d'un royaume est pendu un feu
de circulation puis brûlé sous les
applaudissements de la foule
[Applaudissements]
la gauche est vraiment frustré à durer
60 jours clap ont été bloqués il avait
une grande cause des problèmes urgents
les semaines avancent les tentatives de
négociations semblent mener nulle part
ne pouvons pas accepter de négocier sous
la pression des armes
excédé le mouvement solidarité
châteauguay dirigée par un ancien
policier de la sûreté du québec occupe
le pont le vie de saint louis de
gonzague et bloquent la fois maritime on
reste ici tant qu'elle peut remercier
pas débloquée je suis la police à nous
arrêterons front remorquer les véhicules
ils feront ce qu'ils voudront mais ce qu
intervient avec force
rien pour calmer les résidents
dès la sortie du québec est intervenue
mais matra qui arrêtent les manifestants
non autochtone quand les forces armées
sont intervenues sur le pont c'était
plus de problème de khost est sûre paix
sociale parce que du côté des jeunes
autochtones on sait qu'on allait fermer
aussi en était rendu losc fut un enjeu
territorial au col saint ange de paix
sociale lorsque l'armée a ri les
ouailles aux postés à kahnawake
abandonnent leurs barricades
on découvre alors un imposant arsenal
quand des personnes âgées des enfants
work évacue la réserve des résidents
châteauguay et leur lance une pluie de
projectiles
des dizaines de policiers de la sûreté
du québec sont pourtant sur place ils ne
font qu observer la scène sans broncher
le pour mercier finalement rouvert
l'armée resserre l'étau à cannes et
s'attaquer
soldats et oies rieuses sont maintenant
un face-à-face l'image fera le tour du
monde puis à la fin septembre des
derniers rois yeux et leurs
sympathisants essaie de fuir sans leurs
armes
surpris les soldats fusil et baïonnettes
à la main bloquent le passage après 78
jours la crise se termine dans la plus
grande confusion